you both have to go through such a huge
range of emotions like from love to like
absolute despair was there a day that
was tricky emotionally or difficult for
you I think on a kind of general basis
the trying to imagine that that feeling
of entrapment and helplessness was kind
of a constant baseline you know for
everything so I mean that was just
difficult to imagine because I've never
been in a situation even close to this
one thing I loved about sci-fi as a
genre is how its set in the future but
it actually comments on the time that
we're living in so what did you guys
think about when you were making
passengers was there any big concepts in
regards to how it like is timely now I
think you know gar need to connect with
other human beings and to have something
to love and someone to love also you
know having a purpose something that
drives you something that motivates you
something that you can create yeah
that's exactly why I love science
fiction I'm fantasy I suppose it kind of
makes you think that you're having
escapist entertainment but actually all
it does is show us in a different way
you know relate to us so I suppose the
thing that I kept coming back to with
playing Arthur was he's not human he's a
he's a robot he's programmed but his
programming is all about anticipating
the needs of his customers and the one
thing that Jim wants is another human
being so you've got this robot who's
trying to be human and in in bumping up
against his own limitations as a robot
that's what makes him human I realized
it's it's the struggle to be human that
makes us human
were you friends beforehand or did you
meet no II meant and then we mean now
we're like no no we became we became we
had never met one another until you know
starting to work on this movie and then
you know spent 16 hours sometimes 17 18
hours a day on on this set and he knows
everything I know everything I know
everything there's no yeah we went we
went we went deep we got deep almost
immediately like we're like oh I'm gonna
tell you every day
so we
just like you know and it was nice it
was cool we got a great movie out of it
but also you know just as importantly if
not more than portent Lee for us a good
friendship that'll last forever
this reason we woke up early
[Music]